WE HAVE A TRADE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT ABOUT A FORMER M.V.P.
HEADING TO LOS ANGELES LAKERS.
FIRST, CADE CUNNINGHAM, THE
NUMBER ONE OVERALL PICK KEEPS A
STREAK INTACT.
12 STRAIGHT YEARS THAT A
ONE-AND-ONE PLAYER GOES FIRST
WITH THE DRAFT AND FIRST WITH
THE INTERVIEW IS OUR VERY OWN
TAYLOR ROOKS, WHO CAUGHT UP WITH
CADE CUNNINGHAM.
TAYLOR: CADE CUNNINGHAM, THE
NUMBER ONE OVERALL PICK --
HEADING TO THE PISTONS, WHAT
EMOTIONS COME WITH HEARING THOSE
WORDS OUT LOUD.
CADE: A BUNCH OF EMOTIONS.
MORE THAN ANYTHING IT IS
HAPPINESS, EXCITEMENT, AND I AM
GLAD I GOT TO SPEND THIS MOMENT
WITH MY FAMILY, HAVE THEM IN
HERE WITH ME.
EXPERIENCE THIS.
IT IS A BIG MOMENT.
MY SUPPORT SYSTEM IS WHAT HELPED
ME GET TO THIS POINT.
IT IS A BLESSING TO BE INVOLVED.
TAYLOR: YOU ALWAYS SAID YOU
WOULD BE THE NUMBER ONE PICK, SO
MUCH SO YOU ONLY MET WITH
DETROIT.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN ABOUT THE
ROLE THE PISTONS FOR YOUR
FUTURE?
CADE: MORE THAN ANYTHING THEY
WANTED TO PUSH ME TO BE THE BEST
I COULD BE.
WHEN I WAS TALKING TO THEM, WHAT
WAS MOST IMPORTANT TO ME IS THAT
THEY WEREN'T GOING TO TAKE IT
EASY ON ME.
THEY WERE GOING TO PUSH ME TO BE
GREAT.
I LEFT FEELING GREAT, LIKE I WAS
STEPPING INTO A GREAT SITUATION.
AND NOW I'M EXCITED TO BE ABLE
TO GO DELIVER FOR THEM.
TAYLOR SO MANY EXPECTATIONS COME
: WITH BEING THE FIRST PICK.
TELL ME ABOUT THE EXPECTATIONS
YOU THINK OTHER PEOPLE'S HAVE --
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE FOR YOU AND
THE EXPECTATIONS YOU HAVE FOR
YOURSELF.
CADE: YOU WANT TO COME IN AND
ELEVATE AN ORGANIZATION.
THE EXPECTATIONS I HAVE HAD ON
MYSELF, FOR EVERY TEAM I HAVE
PLAYED ON, I WANT TO LOOK BACK
ON MY CAREER AND BE PROUD OF THE
THINGS I HAVE DONE.
I'M GOING TO TAKE PRIDE IN
MAKING SURE I CAN DELIVER FOR
DETROIT, THE CITY OF DETROIT,
BEING THE GUY THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR.
TAYLOR: I SEE YOUR ADORABLE
DAUGHTER OVER THERE.
CADE: SHE IS CUTE, ISN'T SHE?
TAYLOR: SO CUTE.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT KIDS,
THEY GO WITH THE FLOW.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH DAD?
CADE: SHE GETS THE JUST EVERYONE
IS SHARING FOR ME.
WE HAVE THE VIDEO.
DOWN THE ROAD SHE WILL BE HAPPY
TO RELIVE THE MOMENT.
TAYLOR: DAD IS OFFICIALLY NBA
PLAYER.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WATCHING A
LONG CAREER FOR YOU IN THE
LEAGUE.
CHRIS: A6'8" SHOOTER -- REMINDS
ME OF ANOTHER GUY ON THIS SET.
WHAT IS CADE CUNNINGHAM BRING?
STEVE: I AM SITTING NEXT TO
BRIAN SHAW -- WE BOTH PLAY THE
POSITION.
WE COULD HANDLE THE BASKETBALL.
I AM BIAS TO A GOD THAT IS 6'8",
THAT CAN HANDLE THE BASKETBALL.
WHAT I LOVE, YOU CANNOT SPEED
HIM UP, EVEN OFF THE COURT.
HE IS READY FOR THE MOMENT.
HIS SUPPORT SYSTEM HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT IT, EVERYBODY
TALKED ABOUT HE IS NOT THAT
ATHLETIC.
A GUY NAMED JOKIC FROM DENVER, I
DON'T THINK HE IS JUMPING OVER
THIS PIECE OF PAPER AND HE WON
THE M.V.P..
WHEN YOU HAVE A HIGH BASKETBALL
IQ AND YOU UNDERSTAND THE GAME,
YOU WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
THE REASON I LOVE HIM, WATCHING
HIM PLAY IN COLLEGE, HE WAS THE
FIRST, SECOND AND THIRD OPTION
AND HE WASN'T SELFISH BUT HE
COULD STILL GET HIS POINTS AND
MAKE OTHERS BETTER.
HE IS READY FOR THIS MOMENT.
HE IS BUILT FOR THIS MOMENT.
AT 6'8", WHETHER HE BECOMES A
POINT GUARD THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER, HE WILL HAVE A DEFINED
POSITION IN THE LEAGUE BECAUSE
HE HAS A HIGH IQ AS A BASKETBALL
PLAYER.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
BASKETBALL PLAYERS AND HE IS ONE
OF THEM.
CHRIS: BRIAN, WHAT POSITION DOES
HE PLAY IN THE LEAGUE?
BRIAN: IT IS A POSITIONLESS
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
HE WILL BE WHATEVER POSITION
THEY NEED HIM TO PLAY.
HE WILL DO WHAT THEY NEED HIM TO
DO ON THE COURT.
1, 2, 3, HE BRINGS A LOT OF
SAVVY.
HE BRINGS POISE, PATIENCE.
HE HAS THE SIZE, THE BASKETBALL
IQ, TO SMITTY'S POINT.
WHEN YOU SAW THE INTERVIEW,
DETROIT AND THEIR FANS CAN'T
HELP BUT BE HAPPY WITH WHAT HE
IS GOING TO BRING.
THIS MOMENT IS NOT TOO BIG FOR
HIM.
THE MATURITY LEVEL THAT YOU SEE
THAT HE EXUDES WHEN HE SPEAKS,
HE WILL BE A GREAT LEADER FOR
THAT TEAM AND I THINK HE WILL
COME IN AND WOULD TREMENDOUS
JOB.
ANDY: THEY COULD HAVE MESSED
THIS UP.
THEY DIDN'T.
SOMETIMES WITH THE NUMBER ONE
PICK IN CERTAIN DRAFTS, YOU CAN
TAKE A SWING AND MISS.
DETROIT.
TO YOUR POINT, IT IS ABOUT WINS
AND LOSSES.
WE KNOW THAT.
THE MANAGEMENT TEAM IN DETROIT
KNOWS IT AS WELL.
BUT THEY ARE GETTING A COMPLETE
PERSON.
SOMEONE WHO IS READY FOR, AND
WILL EMBRACE, ALL THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT COMES WITH
BEING THE NUMBER ONE PICK ON A
FRANCHISE THAT IS DESPERATE TO
HAVE A FACE FORWARD PLAYER,
SOMEONE WHO CAN GO OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE KNOW HOW PRIDEFUL PEOPLE IN
DETROIT ARE.
STEVE: YES, INDEED.